best known as the young golden-haired
woman living alongside humankind's
closest relatives this scientist turned
activist has devoted her life to
understanding and working to save
chimpanzees from near extinction her
unorthodox methods of observation
revolutionized how scientists conduct
animal research in the wild debunked
long-held assumptions about primate
behavior and showed the world how much
we have in common with the animal
kingdom let's learn more about the
legendary British primatologist
ethologist anthropologist and un
messenger of peace Jane Goodall Valery
Jane Morris Goodall was born in London
England on April 3rd 1934 she was the
oldest of two girls born to father
Mortimer and engineer turned race car
driver and to mother van a successful
novelist exactly four years following
Jane's birth her younger sister Judith
was born and completed the family this
happy foursome though it would be short
lived with World War two declared in
England in 1939 Jane's father enlisted
and was posted to France from then on he
would become a distant figure in Jane's
life only rarely coming home when he was
on leave after the Allies declared
victory in the war was over the good old
marriage mother ended in divorce a few
years before Jane must have known it was
coming the youngster wrote a heartfelt
letter to her father pleading him to
wait until she was 12 years old the
divorce of Jane's parents Mayer had a
greater impact on her if her mother
hadn't been such an influential and
supportive parent jane says it was her
mother primarily that encouraged her to
live out her passions saying Jane if you
really want something and if you work
hard take advantage of opportunities and
never give up you will somehow find a
way a mother would later play a role in
Jane's early career traveling with Jane
and staying on the camp at the Gombe
reserve Jane spent the majority of her
childhood growing up in her maternal
grandmother's 1872 Victorian house in
the resort town of Bournemouth on the
south coast of England they had a yard
with the garden and trees where Jane
spent most of her free time surrounded
by women
Jane shared the residence with her
mother sister Gran's mother and two arts
it was a happy home and a place Goodall
now in her 80s goes back to when she
needs to relax and recharge
she says all my childhood books the
trees I climbed as a trials the cliffs
I walked and dust in this way
[Music]
young jane develops an early fascination
with wild animals at just over a year
old Jane's father gifted her a lifelike
three foot tools stuffed chimpanzee that
she affectionately named Jubilee and
carried around with her everywhere
Jane's mother's friends were quite
horrified by the toy chimpanzee fearing
it would give the young toddler
nightmares
quite the opposite though Jane loved the
toy and she still has it over 80 years
later being that Jane devoted her life
to researching and saving chimps the
early gift of a stuffed chimpanzee seems
like the ultimate foreshadowing
but Jane admits she is keen on all
animals and would have studied another
species if the circumstances had been
different in fact as a girl Jane did not
limit herself to learning about just one
kind of animal Jane will often be
outside the family home in the yard
quietly observing sketching or writing
notes about birds and other creatures
her family had a host of pets including
a tortoise and dog and the young Jane
took in many more including racing
snails caterpillars a lizard and a
canary Jane was an avid reader to some
of her favorite books included Doctor
Dolittle Tarzan and the jungle book
reading these books ignited a desire to
go to Africa some day to observe and
write about wild animals Jane was also a
curious and patient youngster once when
Jane was 5 years old her parents could
not find her and presumed her missing as
panic ensued and search began it turns
out Jane had been sitting in the
henhouse waiting for the chickens to lay
eggs this quiet observation and
persistence is the hallmark of how
Goodall would later conduct her research
at Gombe stream while Jane entertains
fanciful thoughts of Africa and longed
to be outside in nature she was still
young and enrolled at the Upton's
private school by all accounts she was a
good students but felt the routine of
the classroom unbearable at 16 she
confided in her diary writing woke up to
be faced by yet another dreary day of
torture at that gloomy place of
discipline and learning where one is
stuffed with education from days dawn to
days Eve despite these feelings that he
managed to embrace her school studies
and finished strong focusing her
interests in biology and English she
even won two prizes for essay writing in
1953 and at the urging of her mother
Jane enrolled in the London's Queen's
secretarial College and graduate
one year later after receiving a
qualification Jayne health clerical jobs
in Bournemouth and Oxford University she
also sometimes waited tables and took a
part-time job with a film company still
Jayne never gave up on her dream of
going to Africa
even if the idea seemed far-fetched in
1955 Jayne girl received a letter from
Chlo and old school friends with an
invitation to come to Kenya the day had
finally come it was the opportunity that
she had been waiting for
she saved hard for the fair and in March
of 1957 embarks on a three-week journey
by ship soon after arriving in Kenya
Jayne took a job in the capital city of
Nairobi and met to the famed British
paleontologist Louis Leakey who was then
the curator of the Natural History
Museum the Koren doll museum Jane at
this point was just 23 years old
Nikki asserted Charles Darwin's theory
of evolution and believed humans
originated in Africa he was motivated to
find the missing link and was searching
for just the right person to study
primates in the wild rather than in
captivity research of apes in their
natural habitat has not been carried out
before in this manner and Leakey soren
Jane the perfect candidate to conduct
the study not only did Jane exhibit the
enthusiasm he was looking for but she
also had the temperament to sustain long
periods of time in the African bush with
a mind uncluttered and unbiased by
theory up until this time Goodall has no
formal scientific training or academic
credentials that qualified her to
conduct such a study not to mention
women scientists were practically
unheard of during the 1950s and 1960s
nevertheless Leakey took a chance on the
young women first hiring her as a
secretary and then sending her to the
Gombe stream Reserve in Tanzania in 1960
Jane was earned her PhD later in 1965
from Cambridge University the degree
would earn Jane respect in the field and
allow her to receive funding for
research
[Music]
in 1960 at the age of 26 Janne Google
embarked for the gamba stream reserve
now part of the Gombe National Park in
Tanzania gamba is bordered by the
longest lake in the world
Lake Tanganyika in the Goma region of
the country in 1960 when Jane began her
research the forests of gamba were part
of a continuous chain throughout Burundi
Rwanda and Uganda and stretched
westwards to the great Congo Basin
Jane's destination was only accessible
by boat and the land was characterized
by steep valleys and lush green rain
forests the African bush and waters were
alive with many species of wildlife
birds and fish today it remains one of
the best places on earth to observe
primates in their natural habitat
Goodall's mission was to learn
everything she possibly could about the
wild chimpanzees
while in gamba her mother accompanies
her on the trip for the first few months
the local authorities believing a young
British woman would never survive alone
in the wilderness
perhaps they were right though the
dangers of nature were less of a concern
at the time civil war in the Congo had
flooded gamba with refugees for several
weeks Jane her mother and one cook were
forbidden to travel to the stream and
waited out the conflict in a prison camp
until it was safe again thinking back on
her first day and gone bear Jane
recalled looking up from the short of
forest hitting the Apes and the birds
and smelling the plants and thinking it
was very very unreal
Jane's early attempts at getting close
to chimpanzees failed she could no
closer than 500 yards she found another
troop and established a pattern of
consistent observation by appearing in
the same spot each morning along the
kekambas stream near the chimps feeding
area it was one male chimpanzee who
allowed Jane within close range she
tempted him with the odd banana and
named him David Greybeard for his white
tufted chin once he allowed Jane to get
close and watch him other members of the
troop started to feel comfortable and
accept her presence no other human up
until now had ever gotten so close to
chimpanzees in the wild it would take
two years for the chimps to show no fear
of her and she was allowed to observe
them almost as if she was a chimp
herself Jane imitated them aid their
foods and spent time in the trees she
would become closely acquainted with
over half of the 100 or so chimps in the
reserve much to the horror of some
scientists Jane gave all the chimps
names like Flo thief
flint and mr. Gregor at this time one
was careful not to give human
characteristics to animals for fear of
engaging in anthropomorphism researchers
tended to use the numbers instead
Goodall would later recall these people
were trying to make apology a hard
science so they objected quite
unpleasantly to my naming my subjects
and for suggesting that they have
personalities minds and feelings critics
aside Jane continued her practice she
believed that empathy was the key to
detecting slight changes in mood or
attitude and those changes could provide
insights into complex social processes
[Music]
within weeks it got bad Jane was making
new discoveries and turning conventional
thought on its head making tools and
using tools was thought to be an
exclusive trait of humans and not
animals yet Jane witness david gray
third using a blade of grass to extract
termites from mounds and on another
occasion he stripped leaves from a twig
to gain better access to his prey this
was the first recorded time in history
that another species had used or
modified tools Leakey was so excited he
famously exclaimed we must now redefine
man redefine tool or accepts chimpanzees
as human he was surely exaggerating but
the discovery was a major blow to the
notion of man the toolmaker a few weeks
after the tool-making revelation Jane
observed David Greybeard eating what
looked like a piece of meat it was a
piglets and so the long-held theory of
primates as strictly vegetarians well
that was also debunked through Jane's
observations the world would also learn
chimps engage in cannibalism and warfare
Jane witnessed a brutal four-year war
with a neighboring tribe that devastated
the chimps male chimps also routinely
patrol the borders of their territory
and will attack a solitary male
chimpanzee from another tribe in order
to protect their area this dark side of
chimpanzee behavior Jane Goodall
lightened to gang activity living
amongst the primates Jane observed the
chimpanzees have complex brains and
social systems the caste system of
chimpanzee society places the dominant
male at the top which is often ranked by
how intense his performances at feedings
over the course of her research
Jane discovered chimps to develop
long-term bonds with each other have
ritualized behaviour and even a
primitive language with 20 unique sounds
chimpanzees possess individual
personalities and communicate through
touch and body language they kiss and
embrace each other give Pat's on the
back shake their fists and engage in a
whole variety of other nonverbal ways
Jane noted the male's do not play an
active role in the family this is simply
left up to the females
Jane observed the strong bond in the
mother-child relationship and found that
maternal instincts are taught not
inherent chimpanzees learn through
observation imitation and practice the
chimpanzees with good mothers who were
above all else
supportive ended up being good mothers
themselves the ones who were poor ended
up having female offspring
there was also poor mothering Jane even
theorized that chimps may have a sense
of self and perhaps a spiritual
connection her research concluded that
mother centric groupings along with sex
food sharing and grooming are the
essential components of chimpanzee
society qoodles publication the
chimpanzees have gone bare patterns of
behavior is the definitive work on the
behavior of chimpanzees it would become
the core body of work used to establish
chimps gorillas and bonobos as hominids
the early discoveries of tool-making and
meat-eating shrimps and the idea of a
young woman living in the jungle caught
the interest of National Geographic and
in 1962 they sent the dashing Dutch
photographer Baron Hugo van Loic to film
her work the two fell in love while on
assignment as they went in 1964 three
years later they had their son Hugo
Junior who she called grub life seemed
idyllic for Jane doing what she loved
most being with and writing about
chimpanzees vanlowe eggs film this
Goodall ends the wild chimpanzees ed in
1965 and thrusts Jane into the spotlight
in that same year Jane received her PhD
from Cambridge even though it was
Leakey's idea and he pushed Jane to
pursue her doctorate she acknowledged it
was important saying that Cambridge
taught me to think in a scientific way
so I could stand up to people it taught
me to think logically I loved it and I
loved analysing the data it was a very
important part of my development Jane
and Hugo's marriage lasted a decade and
by 1974 the pair called it quits yes
they remained on good terms she had
married Derek Bryson member of Tanzanian
Parliament and director of Tanzania's
National Parks the following year they
had five good years together until its
death in 1980 from cancer Jane was
devastated by the loss but she came to
terms with us I went to gamba and the
forest is very healing you get this
endless cycle of living and dying and
things fell into perspective in 1971
Jane Goodall published one of her most
popular and well-known books in the
shadow of man her vivid descriptions
brought the chimps to life and bridged
the gap between science and
entertainment Jane published many more
books after she held a professorship at
Stanford University and was appointed
honorary visiting professor of zoology
at the University of Dar es Salaam in
Tanzania in 1977 dr. Goodall founded the
Jane Goodall Institute JG
I with a mission to protect the
chimpanzees and further the research
gamba the soft-spoken Jane seemed an
unlikely celebrity but she would find
her academic respectability and
popularity an advantage when speaking on
behalf of the chimps that she so loved
over the course of her research at Gombe
it became increasingly clear the
wildlife there including the chimpanzees
were at significant risk in fact by the
1980s chimpanzees were an endangered
species their home and resources were
being destroyed at an alarming rate
after attending a conference organized
by the Chicago Academy of Sciences in
1986 to coincide with the publication of
the chimpanzees of Gombe Goodall found
herself at a turning point at 52 years
olds and after 25 years of field
research Jane went on the road to
educate the public on the vanishing
habitats the bushmeat trade animal
trafficking and the unethical Treatment
of Animals used in modern medicine and
for scientific research in 1990 the
revelation came that Jane must turn her
attention to humans in order to save her
chimps while flying over Gombe she saw
the hill stripped bare by deforestation
the local villages were responsible
having over farms their land with little
options left they had taken the trees in
the National Park to sell us timber in
order to survive
at that moment Jane realized that unless
you address poverty and work to improve
the lives of villages you can never
expect do conserve the lands and save
the wildlife she explains everything's
interconnected you learn that in the
rainforest
soon after the jgi launched programs
focused on education family planning
water management sustainable agriculture
and microcredit for women
thanks to our work with the Jane Goodall
Institute's Lake Tanganyika catchment
reforestation and education project the
gamba chimps now have three to four
times more forests than they had ten
years ago I work on the ethical
treatment of captive chimps at the
medical community to steer away from
their using cross species organ
transplants also known as
xenotransplantation further Goodall has
made strides to phase out the use of
chimpanzees in medical research
Goodall works tirelessly an average of
300 days per year to spread the mission
of the jgi the Institute has offices
around the globe with programs primarily
in Africa to involve the local people in
community centered conservation another
initiative the roots and fruits program
is an operation in over 130 countries
and works to foster environmentalism and
peace among the world's children girdles
passionate fight to preserve the world's
chimpanzee population has included
service on the Save the Chimps port the
world's largest chimpanzee sanctuary
located in Fort Pierce Florida over a
long career good or became the world's
expert on primates her fieldwork has led
to the publication of numerous articles
and five major books she has also
written a number of children's books
such as grub the bush baby chimpanzees I
love and my life with the chimpanzees
countless people over multiple
generations have gotten to know her work
through the National Geographic magazine
television programs and IMAX film Jane
Goodall's wild chimpanzees Jane a new
documentary film by brett morgan was
released in 2017 to critical acclaim and
features over 100 hours of archived
National Geographic footage the
Trailblazer Jane Goodall is still
captivating audiences all this time
later Goodall has received numerous
honors and awards including a gold medal
of conservation from the San Diego Zoo
illogical Society in 1974 the Jaipur
Getty Wildlife Conservation Prize in
1984 the Schweitzer medal of the animal
welfare Institute in 1987 the National
Geographic Society centennial award in
1988 the Kyoto Prize in basic sciences
in 1990 the National Geographic Society
hubbard medal for distinction in
exploration discovery and research in
1995 and in 2002 she was named messenger
of peace by the United Nations in 2003
she became a dame of the British Empire
and in 2006 she was honored with the
60th anniversary medal of the eunice
and French Legion honor she also holds
multiple honorary doctorates from
various prestigious universities around
the world
[Music]
James research continues at the Gombe
stream Research Center established by
Goodall in 1965 it is the
longest-running study of chimpanzees the
world has ever seen
the Center hosts visiting researchers
and continues to further our
understanding of chimpanzee health group
dynamics diet and more the information
gathered here can also inform
conservation efforts these days Jane
visitors the center at least twice a
year but all the trims she knew have now
passed on Jane's legacy is more than a
contributions to science or her activism
her determination and body of work
inspires us to believe in ourselves and
remember our connection to nature and
what we leave behind she wants us to
think about the Earth's future and our
role in protecting it saying I care
passionately about nature I care
passionately about children I have three
grandchildren I think about their
children if we can't do things
differently what is the world going to
be like in 50 years above all else
Jane has taught us that it is up to us
to make a change every individual
matters every individual has a role to
play every individual makes a difference
only if we understand well we care only
if we care where we help only if we help
shall we all be saved the least I can do
is speak out for those who cannot speak
out for themselves so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic s--
if you did there's a couple of things
you could do right now one is hit that
like button below also if you want more
stuff like this we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday where we put out a
new video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching